- I'm pleased to introduce Merav Shohet
who is an Assistant
Professor of Anthropology
at Boston University.
She works at the intersection
of cultural, medical
and linguistic anthropology,
and has been publishing
at a rapid clip in all the
top journals in anthropology
including "American Anthropologist",
"American Ethnologist",
"The Journal of the Royal
Anthropological Institute"
and many more prestigious journals.
She's been even writing
about eating disorders
in North America, although
today it's her work on Vietnam
which we'll be listening
to in her presentation.
The Vietnam work, which
I'm quite familiar with
is truly pathbreaking.
She's not only interested in care
and intersubjective
relationships as a topic of study
but her work is notable for
the care and sensitivity
she brings into her ethnography.
She engages ethnographically
with Vietnamese concepts
like sacrifice, hy sinh and
sentiment or love cảm tình
but in the process, her own work appears
as a kind of the ethic
laid in careful offering.
And I mean that we're careful,
not only in the sense of being meticulous,
but as being an act of care itself,
that is her work is full
of care and compassion
as well as rigorous
linguistic analysis of person
referencing everyday greetings.
And it's not too often that
you see care and compassion
in rigorous linguistic
anthropological analysis.
So it's a truly remarkable achievement.
In the subtle but beautifully
rendered stories and episodes
relayed by Merav's work, we
see how the most mundane,
everyday acts are imbued with the stuff
that makes people into people
and how everyday Vietnamese
engage in the literal work
of coming into being as
intersubjectively entangled humans,
that beautifully evocative
phrase in Vietnamese,
(speaks in foreign
language) to make a person.
I'll stop here and please
join me in welcoming Merav
for today's talk which
will be a discussion
of her brand new book,
"Silence and Sacrifice:
Family Stories of Care and
the Limits of Love in Vietnam"
which is just out now
from the University of California Press.
So please join me in welcoming Merav.
- Gosh, thank you all,
I think I should let Erik
actually present about my book.
I'm so honored to have you all here
and to share a bit about my book today.
I'm gonna try to screen share right now.
So I just wanna thank
all of you for being here
and Erik for inviting me and
giving me this opportunity,
and Chris, for arranging it.
And I'll just launch
right in to talk a bit
about "Silence and
Sacrifice: Family Stories
of Care and the Limits
of Love in Vietnam".
And I know that we are all
pretty zoomed out probably,
it being April and a
year into the pandemic.
So I'll try to keep it not too long
but do feel free to
interrupt me at any time,
especially in the first part,
when I'm just talking
about some of the concepts
of the book, and then I'll
move on to give a few excerpts
from chapter four of this book.
And the book is really
organized in three parts
with the introduction setting
up the scene, the concepts,
and then breaking down
the three basic principles
that I see as organizing
and structuring life
and especially kind of life experience
and ethical subjectivity of
my interlocutors in Vietnam
and that's sacrifice
asymmetrical reciprocity,
an cam tinh, that we'll be talking about.
And then the second part of
the book emphasizes a lot more
of the complications on the ground
especially as people in
Da Nang and Quang Nam
who had more tenuous
connections to the state
and had kinda ghosts haunting
them at times from the past.
So looking at how these
principles play out in practice
when we study them in Ch2.
The research obviously was in Vietnam
specifically in Da Nang and Quang Nam,
and I conducted the fieldwork a while ago
in 2002 until 2008.
And then it took me quite a
number of years to process
all of the data and make sense of it.
So I spent a total of about
18 months in the field
with 13 consecutive ones in 2007, '08,
and I studied families.
And so I did a lot of household surveys,
kinda looking at family composition
and routines and that kind of thing,
and that was about 80 households.
And then among those or including those,
I studied five focal families,
they we're all extended families,
they were multi-generational,
multi-household,
60% of them lived in
multi-generational units.
Most of them were middle class,
and this relied on participant
observation on interviews,
on person-centered interviews
except what I came to see it
as because I was looking at
multiple members within a family
instead of just individuals,
I came to see it as a
family-centered ethnography
which I think enriches the notion
from psychological
anthropology of person-centered
where you look at people,
not just as tokens of a type
but really as individuals
in their own rights.
I also did a number of recordings,
I went to each family about
every four to six weeks
and in total had 94 hours of recordings,
which obviously with their permission
and I had thousands of photographs
and notes and all that.
So I'm not sure if I'll ever be able
to transcribe everything
but I did a lot of it
with the assistance of local assistants
and then also native speakers
in the U.S. and Canada.
And so I did originally mean to study
silence and sacrifice per se,
but really what I was interested in
is what holds families
together in the face of change.
And that was because in Da Nang
where the Americans had
landed during the war
and were situated,
all of the families I
studied had been torn.
They had some members who had gone North
to fight for North Vietnam
and some who had stayed,
some affiliated with the
South, with the Americans,
some affiliated with Viet Cong,
some affiliated at times with both.
And so I was wondering having
come a good 30 years later,
how is it that families seemed
so able to to eat together
and celebrate together and walk together
and enjoy each other's company.
And I found that there
are several key components
that help in this.
One of them is hy sinh or sacrifice
which I came to think of as
really willingly silently
and smilingly embracing hardship
for the benefit of
asymmetrically positioned others.
Vietnam is full of hierarchies,
a lot of it organized
around kinship and cam tinh.
So sacrifice, hy sinh, and
I constantly read about it
and sometimes heard about
it in learning Vietnamese.
And cam tinh is something that
I always heard in daily life
as families talk about it.
And so I really wanted to understand
these very basic concepts,
like what do they mean?
How do they work?
How do they help create
the sense of continuity?
And I came to think of them
as really working together
to also reenforce gender norms
and also age and class
and political divisions.
And so in thinking about this,
I was really also interested
in the anthropology of ethics
and morality and how it is
that people enact ethics.
What does it mean to be a virtuous person
in a time of upheaval and
change and rifts and ruptures?
And I saw the beginning
of the 21st century
as yet another moment of change
as Vietnam was continuing with
(speaks in foreign language),
like a market economy where
nationalized forms of care
were increasingly absent.
And I ended up concluding
that despite this ethic
that preaches that people
should be beneficent
to each other, should respect
above and yield below,
this is what I call
asymmetrical reciprocity,
women especially young and poor ones,
and especially in Da
Nang those who had sided
with the losing side of the American War,
shoulder a disproportionate burden.
And this is in part because
of the market forces
that reinforce the
gender and cultural norms
that saddle them with the work of cam,
with putting on the feasts with
navigating the new economy.
And so, as I said, a lot of
this has to do with cam tinh
and hy sinh, sacrifice.
And this is really not
gendered in the ways
that maybe we think of in
American or European terms
as sacrifice being the domain
of men to give their lives
up in war and cam tinh,
love and care as the domain of women.
Everybody participates
in it, in this logic
but not always in uniformed ways.
And in studying this, I'm
really drawing and expanding
on certain anthropological concepts,
our approach to sacrifice has
been largely to think of it
in the dramatic terms
as a religious ritual,
as the act of slaughter or substitution
and relatedly as a patriotic act.
And both of these are highly
dramatic, a kind of spectacle
with bloodshed and I
think what we have ignored
is really the everyday act
of sacrifice in mundane life.
That sometimes I've even gotten push back
when presenting and saying,
well he said this isn't really sacrifice,
and in fact, in Vietnam
it's very much associated
with patriotic sacrifice
but also with a family
and with a feminized work of care,
it's not traditionally
associated with slaughter,
there's other terms for that.
And so in looking at the mundane,
I'm looking at sacrifice in
the beginning of the book
as really kinda scaling
these multiple levels
of both the affiliation with the state,
and in chapter one, I talk
about a man from Quang Nam
who I call Tam, who had
tried to evade conscription
into the French Army in
the 1950s was captured,
was tortured and then in
1954, when Vietnam was split,
he was released in a prisoner exchange.
He went up North and then
spent a good chunk of his life
away from his natal family, and
then also away from his wife
who he married in the
North, because he went back
with a call of duty to liberate the South.
And he talks a lot about sacrifice
and he talks about kind of the
propaganda of Vietnam is one,
nothing is more precious
than liberty and so forth,
but what he also talks about is suffering.
And one of the things I learned from him
and from many others is the ways
that suffering is really
supposed to be silent,
you don't call attention to yourself
when taking it on for somebody else.
And the ways that men, as well as women
oftentimes attribute sacrifice to women,
especially to mothers, this is
kind of the paragon of virtue
it is the sacrificing mother
who tends to her children,
to her husband, to the
nation, to the community.
And so this kind of
guided my understanding
also of the second principle
which is asymmetrical and reciprocity.
And then thirdly, cam tinh
and the ways that these work together
to organize people's experiences of time
and of their relationships
with the two calendars,
for example, in Vietnam,
with the ancestors,
with each other, with the state.
And then in chapter three,
I show among other things
how state discourses, and
attempts to legislate equality
are really in effect and
gendering difference.
And the ways that silence
figures in all of these,
in naturalizing gender
and other hierarchies.
And these are premise of
course, on this presumption
of the unequal, but benevolent
and bi-directional care.
And so oftentimes when we
think of Vietnam's legacy
as Confucian and as Buddhist
thinking about filial piety
and some people have written about it
in terms of a kind of
exploitation from above,
the power from above demanding respect.
In fact, I think that it's more
useful to think of hierarchy
as bi-directional in the ideal case.
But of course, as I noted earlier
this also doesn't always
play out in practice,
there are those who suffer more
and suffer more in silence.
And so then the second half of the book
is traveling some of
these principles of ethics
and morality of sacrifice
and asymmetrical reciprocity.
When I studied them in
practice, looking at families
I think as we need to, if we
want to understand kinship
and relations within a community,
we really need to look
at the multiple people
with their different and
cross-cutting and dynamic
and really intersectional
perspectives and grievances.
And so I wanna turn now to chapter four
to give a sense of this with
some experts from that chapter.
And just before I do that,
I wanna introduce three other concepts
that will help us make sense of these
that I borrow from literary studies.
And that really those are the
concepts of foreshadowing,
backshadowing and sideshadowing narratives
that I use in making sense
of people's experiences
and observations and interactions.
So I'm showing you're all
familiar with foreshadowing,
it's where we see past events
as foretelling future ones.
So for example, if we
start out something with,
it was a dark and stormy
night, we know that this cliche
is going to lead to
some issues and problems
as is the case in any narrative.
And this is often associated
with narratives of progress and modernity.
So in the U.S. the kind of
ideology of manifest destiny
of Americans to move West and conquer
and displace native American peoples,
and in Vietnam too when we think of it
as having the civilization
beginning in the Red River Delta
and moving Southward and
displacing other ethnic minorities
and forming its own heroic civilization.
And backshadowing uses
the same sort of logic
but in reverse in that we
know already what happened.
And then we judge the past
in terms of that knowledge
of the present, the future.
And so both the foreshadowing
and backshadowing
tend to have these linear narratives
with a clear beginning, middle and end
that kind of direct events
with a constant moral stance.
And this is something that
we do all the time in life,
and we oftentimes associate narrative
with these kinds of stories
that come ready-made.
But of course, in life
itself when we don't know
what will happen next and
when we often ruminate
on what might have been, what
steps we might have taken
there was also the
practice of sideshadowing.
And that is really to
think about contingency
and contradiction, which we
constantly encounter in life
when we feel ambivalence,
when things are not so linear,
when things are not so certain,
when there is doubt
and incommensurability.
And so I use these
frameworks to make sense
of how people live the
everyday and the ritual lives
and how they make sense of their life.
And in 21st century Da
Nang, when I was there,
two of the things that
really concern people
were of course, health and wealth.
And those are things that
are sometimes precarious
to have especially in
a marketizing economy
although really in any economy.
And which I saw as that even though people
were not exactly eager
to talk about the past most of the time,
there was really a kind of
ideology of let's move beyond
and let's not think
about the painful past.
At the same time, there was
a kind of long shadow cast
by war when people's
loyalties had been split
and also concurrently the
uncertainty about the future
during that present transition
to market socialism,
(speaks in foreign language)
and so one of the things
I wanna argue is that there
was really no such thing
as privatization which
(speaks in foreign language)
is oftentimes in neoliberalism
is associated with,
by looking and using the tools
of linguistic anthropology
to highlight the micro instances of care.
And here I focus on the moral
rather than the political ecology
of market socialist Vietnam
and illustrate some of the ambivalences
and complexities of care.
And here I begin with two premises.
One is that in focusing
on individuals who care,
I assume not the rightfully maligned
autonomous bounded self-interested persons
that the U.S. usually attribute to Western
or even neoliberal subject
but instead I'm thinking
of persons as relational,
as evaluative subjects, whose
ethics, they come into relief
when we attend to the living narratives
of everyday intervention.
And here again, what I mean by narrative
is not a contained text
but rather how people talk with another
and interact one another to make sense
and to lay moral claims
against one another
as these unfold in time
and in interactions.
And what else too was that
peoples and family caregivers
attempts to provide care is
really fraught with moral peril
and filled with ambivalent silences
that threaten to unravel the relations
in late reform Vietnam.
And so any harmony or continuity
or kind of sense of the ordinary
that we might think of,
these are not ready-made,
these are effortfully achieved
and they're precariously sustained.
And my second assumption is that
in cases of end of life
care, we need competence.
Caregivers, they're constantly striving
in an effort to keep the
dying alive and comfortable.
And yet this competence or incompetence
is at once imminent, it's impending
since we can become incompetent
or competent at any time,
but it's also imminent.
It's inherent in any social interaction,
and that's why it's also fluid.
And throughout fieldwork,
what I sought to understand
is what it means
to be a competent ethical
person in Da Nang.
And I've already published on this,
and it also figures in chapter two,
the ways that children
learn politeness routines
to acknowledge their elders,
and this is actually an incipient form
of subjectivation into the morality,
into the disposition of sacrifice
that has a lot to do with
ancestral worship later in life
and ways of taking on
suffering in silence,
disciplining the body
withholding from yourself.
And these acts are never
private, they're never unitary.
They involve a range of
asymmetrical forms of reciprocity
and they reinforce hierarchies.
And so here I focus on one such instance
and the stories that surrounded,
not in a case of childcare,
but really in a case of older care,
where unlike in America where oftentimes
we think of the end of life
as highly biomedicalized
and this of course exists,
people do go to the hospital,
the person I talk about
did go to the hospital
but ultimately a lot of the
care is done at home by kin
who have to also continue
their daily life,
their worship activities,
their income earning
activities and all that.
And so I focus here on a 75-year old woman
who I call Ba Bay, and she
started complaining to me quietly
back in April of headaches.
And then she suffered minor stroke in July
and then spent weeks in the hospital
and finally returned
home and went right back
to the squatting of food
preparation and cleaning
and taking care of her granddaughters,
and she suffered another stroke.
And this time she went into
a permanent vegetative state
and the family was essentially
waiting for her to die.
But they didn't know when she might die,
and they shrouded this
calamity in silence.
So Ba's husband, Ong, he
coped by sleeping a lot
and saying very little,
and the families women
were the ones who really
stepped in to fill the vacuum
and manage the loss with
material acts of caregiving.
And so again, she spent
several months in the hospital
hooked up to machines and then in the end,
in the face of mounting costs,
she returned home in December.
And so she lay in the bed,
placed in the living room
tended by her daughters
and daughters-in-law,
and what I wanna focus here right now
is on just a minute of interaction,
and I'll just show maybe
half a minute of it,
of footage that I filmed in January,
about a month after
she had come back home.
And one of my methodologies
was filming regularly
in the family homes and
I admit I was reluctant
to film a sick and dying
woman, but here she was,
in the living room, the corner
is where the TV used to be.
And the family was like, "Well,
why aren't you filming this?
Why aren't you taking pictures?"
So I did, and so what we see
here or we are going to see
is a little drama unfold
that illustrates how the kin
display care for the dying
and apprentice ethical personhood.
And this emergence socialization routine
begins with Ba lying in
bed, in the living room,
her knees locked upright.
Her daughter-in-law Lan
pleads with a comatose elder
to straighten these out.
Ong who has come to watch
uses the non deferential,
second personal pronoun me,
which only status seniors
use outstatus juniors
to establish hierarchy
as he calls out to Lan
until she looks up to him
and only to tell her
straighten out his wife's legs.
So I'll play this while talking
and then I'll play it again.
So with a smile Lan
answers in a plain voice,
she keeps grimacing.
She then adds this morning I
was able to stretch her a bit
but she's really struggling.
Doesn't matter Ong reassures
but Lan continues with her complaint.
Actually, she's mad at me,
I'm hurting her terribly.
Approaching the bed Ong
mutters, down it hurts.
And then he gazes at as wife
as Lan continues to work on Ba's legs.
Bending over to clearly address
that this is what we see now
Ong states in an authoritative
paternalistic voice,
"Doesn't hurt."
Bending even closer, he exhorts
that in a scolding voice,
"Endure the pain, stretch out the legs,
why stay cramped up?"
His eyes, then focusing on
Ba, he adds in a gentler,
quieter voice, raising
and lowering his chin
in a kind of entreaty,
"Stretch out, stretch out."
Throughout Lan continues to gently press
on her mother-in-law's legs
working to make that work
like with Ong's directive.
She overlaps with him protesting quietly,
I tried doing that while
Ong's sister-in-law
adds her own commands,
"Stretch out the legs, stretch
your legs, lie on the bed."
And I can just do this again.
You all hear me okay?
My computer is kinda...
(indistinct)
So adopting Goffman's
model of participant roles,
we see how the two generations organize
the interaction in gendered
and age graded ways.
It's the daughter-in-law Lan
who physically takes care
of the ill woman there,
while the seniors direct her to keep doing
what she has in fact
been attempting to do.
Lan in turn has little
recourse than to smile, comply,
and only weakly protest that
she has been doing as told.
We learn even more about
responsibility, morality,
and power if we consider the ecology
of this microinteraction.
This includes participants,
eye gaze, movements
and bodily use of space, which
reveal who is interpolated
as a modified participant and how.
From this perspective, the
exchange looks less harsh,
it exemplifies act of care.
Despite Ba's grave condition,
her incompetent caregivers
treat her as a ratified participant.
She's someone to whom they
attribute a will, emotions
and urgency.
Ong scolds, Lan pleads and
imagines are experiences
being scolded and in contrast
with those who are not
there daily to attend Ba,
they at times address her
directly, not just as a mostly
but not yet dead body.
In shorter sense they enact
a we relationship with Ba.
They treat her not as
assumed to be predecessor,
someone who shares
neither the same tenfold
nor spacial frame with
them, but as a consociate,
someone with whom they could
still grow older together.
And this often happens that
people treat each other
as consociates when their ancestors
are directly addressing them,
praying to them and feeding them.
They know that Ba cannot respond
either verbally or with her body.
Yet Ong and Lan read her
nodded brow and stiff limbs
as expressions of pain
and stubborn reprove.
They treat her in other words,
as still endowed with
a rich cognitive life
even though she is motionless,
essentially unresponsive
and on the verge of death, they care.
In this incipient narrative,
Ong's exhortations to stretch
out, models for Lan how to act
in a difficult and
morally fraught instance
where the daughter-in-law
is afraid to hurt
and earn the wrath of her mother-in-law.
In addressing Ba, Ong
indirectly exhorts Lan
to keep on tending to the old woman,
not to allow Ba's limbs to
stiffen and suffer even more.
This is an interpersonal form of care
that does not explicitly
implicate the market.
But though privately
done at home in passing,
it is a public act that demands
recognition and repetition,
and yet Lan and Ong,
we're not professional
end of life caregivers,
they struggle to make Ba comfortable
and to manage their own discomfort.
Most days they did so in muted ways,
Lan smiling and Ong sleeping
in the face of Ba's calamity.
In the absence of prescribed rituals
which are in place for
tending and honoring the dead,
they worked instead at
treating with respect and care,
this matriarch, who
for so long had herself
managed the smooth
running of the household.
They interpolated, not just each other
but also the comment that was there,
as capable of moral action
as eminently competent
and yet imminently incompetent beings
who are engaged in an
ethical project of care
for and about one another.
And this is why the interaction
seems so fraught, I think.
We see unequally
positioned, family members
deliberate fleeting actions
over what the best good
and Sharon Maden Lee's term
is for the nearly dead.
They seem to act in unison,
in agreement that even though
stretching out Ba's legs
causes the inert but to recalcitrant body
and the person inhabiting it, pain
because she's still a living person
and they have to enjoin that
to endure the pain to kill
and to act ethically in this world.
And yet this version of
care and ethical personhood
was precarious, performed
daily in Ba's house
till her eventual death
the following spring,
it enlisted a range of Ba's relatives
who visited periodically
and spoke to and about her.
As they continued to participate
in the households rituals,
no one projected Ba into
the future as an ancestor,
and no one mentioned her imminent death.
They oriented her only as a present
and suffering somewhat indignantly.
I could end by concluding
that these occasions
like Ba's earlier,
quiet endurance of pain,
where for months she did not seek care
for her high blood pressure
reflect local understandings
of gender virtuous care
and daily sacrifice
demanded by an economy
of retracting state care.
But the story doesn't end here,
not everyone regarded Ong
and Ba as innocent victims,
Ong and Ba's niece, An for example,
surprised me one December day
with a story of past
Mungs and transgressions.
I briefly recount this story
and the imminent critique
that Ba's current state
led An to project both
to show how protagonists
are not all equally burdened
with the ethical work
of enduring suffering for
the sake of another silently,
and also to show how
fragile love and care can be
under both marketization
and socialism and under war.
Decades earlier, Ong's brothers
fought on opposing sides
of the American War.
Any of the siblings
always seemed tight-knit,
they kept past divisions mute,
they like to recount
how Ong had done right
by his youngest brother Sen, raising him
and ensuring his education
since their father died young in 1948.
These were compact,
coherent striving narratives
with clear beginnings and
morally predictable endings.
But there is another
sideshadowing genre of narratives.
These stories highlight
ambiguity, ambivalence
and contradiction.
Co-narrated and non-linear
they invite moral reflection
and debate.
In An's meandering story Ong and his wife
appear as withholding or suspending care
during and after the war.
An narrates this tale
of wrongs indirectly,
it's a sideshadowing
story told non-linearly
by weaving back and forth through time,
emphasizing moments of
connection, love and hurt.
Ong and Ba had not
risked losing their house
for sheltering their American
collaborating brother Sen,
nor had they helped his
faithful wife Ma visit him
in communist re-education
camp like Ong's sister
and An's mother Bi had done.
Ong and Ba's passive
acts of omission of care,
which remained implicit and unnarrated,
also turned into sinful
commission when Ong sold off lands
that jointly belonged to all his siblings
and he left Sen's children nothing.
The threads of this story are tangled,
narrating shifting effective
stances, oblique connections
and disagreements that are not resolved,
and these are all worked
out in chapter four.
In sideshadowing fashion,
An presents a series of
contested moral stances
as protagonists hold conflicting
commitments to their kin.
She grieves for the now deceased Ma,
who died after the couple left Vietnam.
But when An was upset
at Sen, for remarrying,
her mother Bi defended him and scolded An,
blood ties trump friendship.
An's story continually
descends into the past
and navigates a presence seemingly blindly
without full clarity of hindsight.
It relies on silences and absences,
not saying that Ong had
not cared for his brother
but pointing out how his sister had.
She tells me, "siblings love,
they take care of each other,
they don't care about whatever happens,
they don't care about money."
And yet An's story is
filled with instances
in which gifts of money
stood for acts of love and refusal to give
was equated with betrayal.
Contradiction pervades her stories
and still one point
emerges clearly at the end
when An's mother Bi,
takes over the telling.
Land price is sold but Ong and his wife
barely shared profits
from the sale of their grandparents land
and refused her even
the smallest of loans.
They didn't care, hearing
Bi and An use backshadowing
using the present hindsight
to morally assess past deeds,
to link Ba's present state
to recent and past wrongs.
Their story which gained steam only slowly
suddenly crescendo to its conclusion.
The present suffering
was karmic retribution
for a life that could
have been led otherwise.
Her voice quietly furious Bi says,
"I asked for so little
but he wouldn't give it.
This was recent before Ba Bay got sick
Ong said he doesn't have it, f***.
We yield to him, whatever he wants."
Mother and daughter
abruptly stopped the account
with these unexpected curse.
Resentments over care withheld
or inadequately performed
which could lie dormant for decades,
came to the surface with
Ba's present illness.
This occasioned imminent
reflection over how to care
and imminent judgment
about who is competent
or incompetent at doing so.
Tensions subtly expressed in instances
such as when Ba's legs
need to be straightened
incite caregivers to
reflect on who has cared
and who deserves caring.
A linguistic phenomenological lens
reveals how temporal horizons
reach into the past and future
both in An and Bi's backshadowing
and sideshadowing stories
that frame the past expectations
and promises unfulfilled
as foregone conclusions
or as unexpected turns.
In Lan and Ong's incipient
and acted narratives,
ethical figures take
shape through complaints,
exhortations and silences.
Bi's stories and silences color
present concerns over care,
condense in Ba's figure lying
on her bed in the living room,
unconscious and unrestful.
Bi is not only sustained
but also threaten to rupture
shared understandings of who
is or was virtuous and why
forcing and forging an
ethics not of cool judgment
but life with cascading
ethic of love and regret.
And so here, I'm talking
about the ways that ethics
isn't really about this
rational withdrawing
and thinking about how to act,
it's also filled with emotion
in trying to behave morally.
And yet still much more was kept at bay,
An and Bi continued to visit Ba,
effectively refusing to
jeopardize rituals of care
and dominant narratives of
virtue despite some tensions.
Their stories where
scornful language erupt
remain almost exclusively silenced.
I conclude then that by tracing
the unfolding emplotments
and intersections of Ong,
An's and Bi's stories
we can witness how precarious,
the world of enduring in
the name of love and care is
and how quotidian sacrifices
remain for the most part,
silence in speech, but
demonstrated in action.
Competence and incompetence
are simultaneously immanent
and imminent and social
life bringing into relief
the moral economy and
politics of care at home
where market constraints
form a mostly silenced
but not invisible template
for what actions seem
possible and desirable.
Here, privatization is not an option,
life is social and fraught to the core.
In the rest of the book,
I continue to show how
participants navigate
these sorts of dilemmas and conflicts,
sometimes choosing
silence, other times gossip
to make claims of one another
in an ethically fraught relational world.
Again and again, we can
disown the cultural patterns
through attention to
the minutia of language
and interaction, which
color, and even constitute
the ways in which families
and communities struggle to cohere.
And these reveal yet again,
the old feminist insight,
that public ethics are to be found
in the after all not so
private domain of families,
families always already
political home lives.
In the conclusion
of the book "Mourning
in silent sacrifice",
I revisit a piece I wrote
for "American Ethnologist"
on the death and funeral
preparations in another family
where we see how the bereaved
attempt to contain their grief.
Here too, I argue that
repetition, like change,
doesn't always beget futurity or natality
in Hannah Ahmad's terms,
even in Vietnamese,
where he sends signals life
and suffering in silence
for the sake of love.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna stop the share
to open it up to discussion
and questions.
- Thank you, Merav.
So everyone we have, well beyond the hour
to engage in question and answer.
You can raise your hand
using the hand raise function
or send a note to the chat
and I'll keep a running list
and then allow Merav to answer
the questions as they come.
So Oscar, did I see your hand go up?
Go ahead.
- Thanks very much Merav,
it's a fascinating story that you told,
really I liked it the stories
but then also the actions,
the silencing as well.
And so it reminds me a
bit of, how to put this?
There was once this Medieval European
or relations European
philosopher, Erasmus Rotterdam.
One of the things that he wrote
was etiquette books, "How to Behave".
And if you would read
these etiquette books now,
it's about don't spit on the floor,
don't relieve yourself
in the corner, et cetera.
Now these things would not be necessary
in most places to remind people of
and (indistinct) Rotterdam,
he was not the only one
who wrote it, it was
like a genre at the time.
(indistinct), on the one
hand, there is an emphasis
about doing something or not
doing something (indistinct),
there's a reality where
this is a bit different.
And your story really reminded me
what people say and like
be completely different
from the (indistinct)
has heard that, (indistinct),
you hear that like a million times, right?
But I'm wondering, could
you reflect on that?
Because I have the deep
suspicion (indistinct),
but masks very often a lack of it,
in the personal relationships,
but reflections about that.
- Yeah, I think I heard the question,
it was very mummed but
I think if the question
that people are constantly
exhorting each other
to perform tinh cam and
absolutely what I saw
with tinh cam is that everybody
is in some ways striving
to do it but in fact,
it's oftentimes weaponized
to use against people.
So you don't say to people,
"Oh you didn't sacrifice enough."
Or, "I sacrificed so much for you
why aren't you doing this for me?"
But the way that they use tinh cam,
even though it's supposed to
have a positive connotation
is always, well, this
person isn't living up
to this standard, you don't show tinh cam,
and that's a lot of what I
show also in chapter five
is the ways that people
gossip about one another
and how it's oftentimes women
gossiping about each other
while kinda letting men off the hook
in expressing how men are
so virtuous for helping
or doing this and that
worshiping, being convivial,
and a lot of times criticizing each other
for not doing enough.
And so really these
principles, they're idealized
and it's very easy to use
a structuralist argument
and say, "Well, this contains life."
But in fact that's really
ethnographically dishonest
to say that these principles
guide every single behavior.
People are oftentimes in
conflict with one another,
and part of it also has
to do with this kind of,
it's not like it's a straight hierarchy
where one dimension encompasses the other,
they intersect and they
rub up against each other.
And this is where tinh cam works
as a way of disciplining people
not just as a way of acting
well or being good and virtuous.
Did I answer that?
- You did, I apologize for
the bad quality of sound.
- Thank you, Merav and
thanks Oscar for the question
and we have a question from David Lindsay.
- Unmute.
Yes, thank you for this,
I've never seen anything quite like that
and it was fascinating,
and it was surprising
how it kept getting deeper and deeper,
I was quite impressed.
I wanna go back to something
in the beginning of your presentation
you talked about asymmetrical reciprocity,
which is something I think I know about
but then you said it's
respect above and yield below.
And I want you to explain
what yield below means.
- Yeah, so essentially this
notion of respect above yield
to those below means that
if you have the means,
if you're a senior, your job,
isn't just to get all the
benefits, to get the respect,
it's also to give, to
yield to those below you
to take care of them really.
So in some ways, for the China scholars,
it's a bit like the guanxi,
sorry if I'm mispronouncing
that, but it's really
about that you are beneficent
and kind of paternalistic
to those who have less than you,
to those who are junior to you.
And this is where we do have reciprocity
and the sense that each side
does things for each other
but this is on a much
longer temporal scale.
And so if parents and grandparents
are taking care of kids, for example,
they're yielding to them.
We see it even with a greeting routine
where the mother corrects
the little baby's posture.
She does it in some ways that
physically she pulls her up
and it's a little bit
harsh, but then the words
and the gestures are also gentle.
And this is how people
I think get socialized
into this idea that you
don't give begrudgingly,
you give willingly.
And when you don't people criticize you
for not really sacrificing or
not really enacting tinh cam.
And so when families put in so much effort
for the ancestors,
it's ostensibly not to
make the ancestors angry.
And it's also to show
each other that they care,
and that they're putting
up these resources
and they're feeding one another.
They're feeding those who
need also in times of want
but there is also the expectation
that the ancestor always give to them.
That they don't punish them,
and moreover, they give them fortune
that you're able to succeed in life.
And so in some ways that's what I mean
by yielding below that it's
not just the upwards directed
but that it's bi-directional,
but not equal.
- Thank you very much.
It's so interesting how
these very Vietnamese affects
are in some ways universal.
- Thank you, David.
And Merav there's a
question from Huetam Tai
in the chat.
Huetam, would you like
to ask your question
or did you want us just
to read it from the chat?
- [Huetam] No, I can ask.
I've had encounters with
Vietnamese women throughout,
actually Central Vietnam.
I was escorting American
teachers and every single guide
talked about how difficult it was to deal
with their obligations
as daughters-in-law.
They were living with the parents-in-law
and they were expected to
care for the mothers-in-law
and sisters-in-law and felt
that it was a real burden,
both physically and emotionally.
So I'm just wondering about
the gender of your informants,
were they mostly women, did you talk a lot
to the men in their families
and was there a difference
in the way they approach
obligations towards parents
or did the men expect that
their wives would take care
of their own parents?
And in the United States
most caregivers are female,
maybe two thirds, three
quarters of caregivers are,
including people who have experience
dealing with things like physical therapy,
I've had experience with
visiting nurses, so I know.
And finally, in a lot of my experiences
women are the ones who
make decisions as to money,
how much they can spend,
how much they can lend out and so on.
So I was wondering again,
when it comes to this
asymmetric relationship,
do women bear most of the burden and why?
Is that something that
is culturally dictated
or specific to the families
that you interviewed?
- I wanna say that yes, as a woman,
I probably interacted
more with women than men
but I didn't exclusively interact
with women also with men.
And what I found is that that saying
about women being (speaks in
foreign language), is true,
oftentimes women also earned
more than their husbands
and that could create some conflict.
Although oftentimes I found
that men kinda took it anyway.
And women do provide a
lot of the caregiving
and do a disproportionate
burden of the cooking,
the cleaning, the tending to kids.
I am a bit reluctant to
make universalist claims,
I think Sherry Ortner does a very good job
of explaining this
culturally, back in the '70s,
as female to male, as
a nature is to culture,
but I think that we can also
find critiques of those.
But I found that surprisingly,
some of the women
actually embraced being
a good daughter-in-law.
In chapter five, I actually have a case
that's a little bit
different where the wife
uses her earning power to
distance herself from the in-laws.
And of course she gets criticized for it,
but she also appreciates the ways
that her husband is extremely filial.
And so we end up having
the husbands sisters
and the wife praising
him for being so virtuous
while they're doing a
lot of the work of care
and conviviality.
And then I also had some families, rare,
but it happens sometimes where
the husband actually lived
with the parents-in-law.
And so yes, women take on more
and I think part of it is that association
of sacrifice being the virtue of women,
that from the very beginning hy sinh
is connected also with
birth, with giving birth.
And so it's a kind of dual-edged discourse
where the expectation that you be moral,
that you give willingly,
that you take care,
that you be virtuous, is
obviously also disciplining
and can be experienced
as hurtful and violent.
And so in that sense,
I think that obviously,
you have so much experience
and I wouldn't discount it at all.
It's very much the case
that women and I would say,
especially it's the poor women
who end up shouldering
a lot of this burden.
- Thank you.
We have a question from Diu-Huong,
Diu-Huong please go ahead,
- [Diu-Huong] Hi every one,
I'm so sorry that my Internet is unstable
so I can't turn on my camera.
So thank you for your talk,
it's really interesting
and I'm so glad to see another research
on the central region of Vietnam.
So I'm just curious though
because when we talk
about Quang Nam people,
Vietnamese people this saying,
(speaks in foreign language)
which is the people from
Vietnam, like to talk back.
And I'm just curious if
your research looked at that
kind of specific characteristics
of the Quang Nam people
and whether those would
affect any of the conception
of hy sinh and tinh cam and
if that change over time,
or if you saw similar
things in Quang Nam, Da Nang
and other location if
you pay attention to that
in other locations as well.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I mean, the majority of research
was in Da Nang and Quang Nam,
so I had much less observations in Hanoi
some a bit in Hoi and
Saigon, Ho Chi Minh City.
Do people talk back?
Of course they do sometimes.
I mean, we're all humans,
but I would say that...
Again, I presented a
framework of how to behave
that people strive to
or criticize each other
for not living up to it sometimes.
But for the most part,
there is that kind of effort
to hy sinh and tinh cam,
even as people yeah,
they talk back.
Yeah, they joke about each other,
yeah they tease, sometimes they hurt.
And so all of it, I don't wanna present
a picture perfect kind
of idea of this stability
that people are solid into their roles,
but rather it's that dynamism
in how they interact with one another
that makes it interesting.
And that's why I find
that attention to language
and particularly the
kind of the microdynamics
of interaction that
helps us see the extent
to which they do or don't
violate certain cultural norms.
Does that make sense
or did I completely
misunderstand your question?
- [Diu-Huong] Yeah,
actually I was thinking
more like the region differences?
- I think that's a great question,
and I feel like having spent
the majority of my time
in Central Vietnam, I
don't think I am the one
best qualified to talk about the North.
I'd say in the North is
actually one of the places
where I heard women
more explicitly complain
about these expectations
that they end up taking on
the role of virtuous wives
at the same time that they
have to do everything else.
But again, I think we have
many people in the audience
that I've done much more
research in the North
that can tell us more about that.
And I would need to go back
and spend significantly
more time in other regions
to make a claim about that.
- Thanks, Merav.
Next question from Qui Ha Nguyen.
- Thank you Merav,
for your fascinating
presentation on the topic.
I'm very interested in the...
Actually my research on
Vietnamese revolutionary cinema
focus on the ideas of
womanhood and motherhood
which somehow share or
overlap in the sense of care,
that is why sacrifice,
which your fascinating research present.
I have a two very brief questions.
The first one is about
the idea of silence.
You talk about silence
in the sense of social
and community presence.
And this link to the point that Diu-Huong
had just presented, I'll pose
it, it is about the locality.
So for that, I would like to ask you
about did you consider
the historical dimension
of the ideas of silence?
Because Quang Nam and Da
Nang, all Central Vietnam,
I'm from Quang Ngai and
then my whole family
and then the neighbor, on the
one hand they share openly
but on as many, many points,
they just keep that for them.
They just don't want
to expose all the pain
that they don't know if it works
for a young generation like me
to share which point they gonna
open up but at some point.
So I would like to ask about the silence
which is linked to the ideas
of historical dimension and
that's particularly linked
to the locality that you
use at Quang Nam and Da Nang
as the place to do your research.
The second question, it is
about the ideas of tinh cam,
and I see that you talk,
and then your research
focus on the ideas of material relation
and is this really amazing
especially you show the clips
where the daughter-in-law
and the whole family
have that kind of interaction.
I have another question,
a question that keep coming up to me
when I was listening to your presentation
is nowadays many people
like Vietnam, they migrate
to Ho Chi Minh City, Hanoi or even abroad
to earn for living.
And that kind of care, material care,
on the one hand is still as you show,
but on the other hand, they
show other form of care,
like they send remittance,
or they do FaceTime chat
every time, like for an hour
or two, similar like that.
And then if your research
actually touch on that
or any other form of care
rather than the material care
that you presented, wonderful already.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Yeah, so with tinh cam, absolutely.
I mean, of course a lot
of it, the most obvious
is the cooking, the cleaning, the tending,
but it is also like
you said the going away
and earning money and sending it back.
And there was so much when
I talk to Vietnamese people
my experience has been from everywhere
but I might be wrong is oftentimes
talking about their mothers
and their parents, hy sinh,
the ways that these
relationships of care continue
and span distances and span generations.
And the same with
silence, I mean of course,
there was the sonic
silence of staying quiet
but there was also that silence
surrounding painful events.
And one of the things that
struck me is, for example,
when somebody died, once they were buried,
you were supposed to hold your feelings in
and not talk about it.
And I think a similar attitude
about kind of that painful past,
the historical suffering of war
was not something that people
generally opened up about.
I have come to wonder
when these things happen,
like at what point generationally.
And I guess I think of
it because my grandmother
was a Holocaust survivor
and she never, ever, ever
spoke about it to us, to the family.
And my mom did not think of her mom much,
like a Holocaust survivor
except sometimes, yes.
But then, my generation is asking about it
and wanting to find out.
And I wonder if in Vietnam
also it's that third generation
and beyond that are asking the questions
that are wanting to hear, and
that maybe as people get older
those who did survive
atrocities and hardship,
but maybe they become more
ready to speak and to open up.
And that one, I think it
just requires more time,
and so maybe when I was there
it wasn't so much spoken
about, but that doesn't mean
that there is gonna be
silence and perpetuity.
And so definitely, I think
that's a great question.
And same with tinh cam,
I mean, it continues in different ways.
It's just that the point
is that it's not like love
isn't just about feelings,
it's also about doings
and you don't have to be right there to do
but that you show through
actions, not just move one word.
So if you say more, I love
you, I love you, I love you,
well, yeah, that's good
but what can you do for me
is the bigger question often.
That makes sense?
- Thank you.
- Thanks, we have a
question from Loni Jones.
Loni, did you wanna ask it yourself
or did you want me to
read it from the chat?
- Sure I can ask.
I'm just thinking about the
purpose of sacrifice and care
more generally not specifically
in this context, I guess.
And I got hung up when
you said the word burden
and I'm just thinking about,
you said there were some
women who did sort of relish
in this work, did you see that very often?
And do you think that's like
a lesser way of being as your,
I guess your focus is kind
of on this unequal dynamics
that you see?
- Yeah, no, that's a great question.
And thank you for calling
me on it because in fact,
it's almost unfair of
me to say burden, right?
Because a lot of women actually, yeah,
they said, "Yeah, my husband could clean,
could cook, and all
that, but I wanna do it,
I wouldn't be a proper
woman if I didn't do it."
And so I think that that
is kind of my imposition
of looking from the outside and
saying, oh, that's a burden.
But from many women,
they do also internalize
and cherish that work, not
always, not all the time,
and that's where if there
is that kind of tension
between a discourse that says,
"Well this is my job, and
this is what I want to do.
And I'm doing it willingly because I love
and because I care and then
sometimes it rubs up against
but I could also be doing other things."
So I think it's absolutely
right of you to question that.
- Yeah, I'm just thinking
about what is the alternative thing to do?
I mean, I guess the unequal
part of it is I guess,
distressing but like what
else is more important
than to care for?
- I mean, but that's the thing, right?
That there is a kind of
sense that in an ideal case
it works out well that you
give some and you get some
and you're not giving the same.
And this is why these acts of
care are not fungible, right?
It's not that I wash your
dishes and you wash my dishes
and where even the idea is
that there is more of
that temporal horizon
that we are constantly in a relationship,
and from creating that (indistinct).
- Creates a relationship, yeah.
- Yeah, through that inequality.
- Really beautiful work.
- Thank you for the great
question and the answer.
Our final question will be from Thuy,
and then what I'll do after
we've answered this question,
I'll stop the recording
and then we'll keep it open
for informal chitchat for
those who would like to stay
another 15 minutes after that.
So go ahead Thuy.
- Okay, thank you.
It's interesting, a very interesting book.
I can see like my whole
family and my other family,
Vietnamese family in your book,
like the condition and how people care.
I have some questions.
The part it says in some
way in your presentation,
you talk about discourses,
and I'm not sure what you
mean by that discourses,
in gender equality or if you have time
to talk more about that when
we are in informal chat.
But another questions is about behavior
and attitudes of the
women like where the...
Because I see in the
video and the pictures.
so much of the women, at
least somehow household women
like staying at home, doing
some not professional jobs.
So whether education and
jobs and economic condition
of the family gender behavior
and attitudes of the women
of the people in term
of care and sacrificing.
Because I see it in my
family and the family
that I saw in Vietnam and
my friend (indistinct)
are gonna have higher education
the attitude is different.
And another one is about Western eyes.
Like, do you think, your Western eyes,
you see I consider you are Western eyes.
You look at this as the outsider
because when I see all of that,
I explain it in different
way in another way,
because like Diu-Huong and many other
talk about the regional differences.
I have two brother in Lao
who are from the center of Vietnam.
And also talk about the doctor in Lao
taking care of the mother-in-law,
because the culture in the center
like on the property of the
family will give to the son.
So they expect the
daughter-in-law to take care
while other family, they
even to share with others.
So usually sometime the
daughter, not the daughter-in-law
take care of their
parents when they're sick.
So when we look at that,
we think about culture
and we see it's very normal
and we think about property,
maybe I give my property to you
and you have to take care of
me, it's your responsibility
something like that, because
we live in that condition.
But under your Western
eyes, it's not correct,
when you just look at how the daughter,
the women taking care of their parents,
and that's about to be
like doing by nurses,
or is it just, through your explanation,
I'm not sure I got it but
through your explanation
is something not right in Western culture
in Western contexts, are like somehow...
So do you think that like your Western eye
affect your explanations?
That's it.
- I am sure that my Western
eyes affect my explanations.
I don't think I was trying to criticize
the system of relations,
quite the opposite.
I was saying that this
is the way it works,
and a lot of times it works quite well.
And I think what it does
help us understand though
is also why does social
reproduction continue?
And a lot of times it continues
not through oppression,
It continues because people
participate in a system.
We collude in a system
and that's not necessarily a bad thing,
it is the way that things are
whether we wanna come in and criticize
that's a different point, but
I'm not sure that we must.
What I found is that I think
because this was a generation
pre the family planning,
and so the people who were
adult and in a position to care
they oftentimes had multiple siblings.
And so care was distributed
among daughters and daughters-in-law.
It wasn't just daughters-in-law,
it wasn't just daughters,
it wasn't just hired help.
The women, I think if you
saw in some of the pictures
these are not necessarily
uneducated women.
What I am saying is that a lot of times
for the worship rituals
and even needing to care
of the mother-in-law, who was fallen sick,
they had to suspend their work,
they had to take time off
and come and take care,
and so that's where there
is a kind of burden.
I also found that men, oftentimes
it didn't really matter
if they're drinking with
their brothers-in-law
or they're drinking with their
brothers, they enjoyed it.
And it was oftentimes
sisters and sisters-in-law
who would do the job of
cleaning up behind them
and of putting together
the system of relations.
But I don't think that
it's necessarily bad,
it's just different.
And I did see one case of a family
that was particularly well-off.
And in that case, the mom actually,
she goes to an ancestral worship ritual
and I talk about it in chapter two.
So she does kind of the
duty, but nominally,
and then she has to run off to work
because she has like
an important position.
And here it is, her
sisters, her hired help,
the sisters-in-law who do the
work of putting on the event
and her husband comes in
and worships in her stead,
so there is always, at least
somebody from the family.
By one say, it's just
women doing all the work
and I wouldn't say that
it's necessarily bad
that women do end up doing
a disproportionate amount
of that kind of work, men also are saddled
with a lot of duties and
burdens and so forth.
But I'm sure that if I wasn't Vietnamese,
I mean if I was Vietnamese,
I would see so much more,
I would hear so much
more, I would understand.
I mean, obviously I'm
not a native speaker,
and so I'm sure I missed a lot.
And I'm sure that if I
had grown up in Vietnam
there was a good chance
I'd be seeing things
differently than I did.
- Thank you Merav,
and thank you everyone for
your wonderful questions
and for joining us for the talk today.
I'm gonna bring it to a close now
but I'm gonna stop the record
here, but please join me
in thanking Merav for a
wonderful talk and discussion.